it's true that there's nothing quite
like a movie where you can download
kungfu directly into your brain but
there are plenty of other trippy amazing
films out there that you love if you're
a fan of the matrix since its released
the matrix really became the gold
standard of movies that asked how real
is our reality everyone who saw it had
to question the world at least for a
moment and wonder if everything we see
and feel everyday actually exists or if
it's all just an illusion there is no
spoon well folks let us assure you we're
not living in a simulation even if there
are some days where we'd actually prefer
to wake up in a goo pod and find out it
was all fake we've just got to make the
best of this reality because it's the
only one we have
or is it director Christopher Nolan's
2010 hit Inception raised this very
question and gave no satisfying answer
but in a very satisfying way starring
Leonardo DiCaprio Ellen Page Tom Hardy
and other superstars this film is packed
with great moments that will stick in
your memory forever even if the plot
leaves you scratching your head similar
to what the Wachowskis achieved with
their masterpiece trilogy the beautiful
filmmaking in Inception pushes the
boundaries of what audiences thought was
possible on the big screen the question
at the core of both Inception and the
matrix is something that's been
contemplated by children and
philosophers for centuries and it's an
idea that rolls around in our human
experience accompanying us our whole
lives
how can we know if what we experience as
reality is truth there's no way to know
for sure but hey if this is a dream a
simulation or some kid snowglobe at
least we've got some great movies to
watch if you've never heard of existence
and you give it a watch after this you
might be shocked that you'd never seen
it before but there's actually a reason
for its obscurity director David
Cronenberg's mind
bending body twisting action flick might
have been a major sci-fi hit but it was
unfortunate enough to be released only a
few weeks after the matrix and it's
similar themes were overshadowed by the
Wachowskis wildly popular visually
stunning blockbuster as a result
existence has flown under the radar as a
cult classic for years but now it's time
to give this film it's jus as one of the
best and trickiest films of the 90s
starring Jude Law and Jennifer Jason
Leigh existence is set in a near future
where game designers a massive
celebrities and the truth about the
world is more complicated than it first
appears this wild ride of the movie
thrills from start to finish with
Cronenberg's signature gross-out body
horror aesthetics some fun and weirdly
squishy shoot-'em-up action and two
compelling actors in its leading roles
it's a little bit darker than the matrix
and as hard as it might be to believe
it's a whole lot weirder to beyond that
though existence definitely has a
similar vibe to its more popular genre
cousin that will surely scratch the itch
when you just got to put more twisty
reality bending plot in your brain tell
the truth are we still looking fans who
love Keanu Reeves for the way that the
matrix redefined action movies for an
entire generation definitely know and
love these movies already if however you
somehow managed to miss the
bone-crushing
senses shattering dog-loving
shoot-'em-up action of John wick and its
sequels get ready for a wild ride Keanu
is at the helm of these hit action
movies starring as the title character
perform a hitman who leaves his old life
of violence behind to find peace with
his wife when the last remnants of his
civilian life are shattered by a group
of thugs who steal his car and kill his
dog John is ready for a fight or two or
200 basically it's the story of a man
who loved a woman
then who loved a dog and who then goes
on the most brutal brazen rampage ever
to grace the silver screen people keep
asking if I'm back and I haven't really
had an answer but now yeah I'm taking on
back John wick and its sequels are a
brutal love letter to fight scenes and
if you've got a taste for a bit of the
old ultraviolence we can guarantee this
is your jam behind the camera there's a
lot to love about this franchise as well
especially if you're a fan of Neos
adventures one of the best and most
prolific stunt people in the film
industry
Chad Stachowski is the director of John
wick along with David leech before
taking the directors gesture he'll ski
was a stunt double for Keanu Reeves in
the matrix and John wick relied on many
of the same stunt coordinators that
helped reinvent action movies back in
1999 plus Laurence Fishburne shows up in
the series as the Bowery King a
character whose every bit as mysterious
as Morpheus and might just be the key to
guiding Keanu through another ultra
violent reality if you love the
philosophical talking points and world
building law behind the story of The
Matrix we can pretty much guarantee that
you'll also love the Animatrix the
lesser-known fourth film in the saga
everyone remembers as a trilogy one of
the more unique entries on this list the
Animatrix is an anthology made up of
nine stories that take place inside and
outside the matrix set between the
Matrix Reloaded and the final events of
the Matrix Revolutions each story is
animated in a totally different style
making this film watchable all at once
or is a set of distinct pieces if that's
more your thing plus you'll see some
familiar faces and hear familiar voices
like neo and Trinity both voiced by
their original actors Keanu Reeves and
carrie-anne moss while it's often
overlooked this is a do not miss film
for any true matrix lover and if you had
the impression that it's just a cartoon
cash-in think again four of the short
films in this movie were written by
that would shall cease themselves
covering a wide array of tales and
emotions on both the human and robot
sides of the story the tales of the
Animatrix are varied in their things
some highlight the strange and simple
beauty of any world humans inhabit or
explore the indomitable will and spirit
the sets Humanity of heart some awesome
shorts fill out more of the history and
give a fuller picture of the world
before the robot uprising that
eventually led to humanity's underground
survival all in all it's a collection of
trippy and beautiful shorts that you
want to watch over and over again in
2008 the Wachowskis took a departure
from the tone of their mind-bending
Matrix trilogy with Speed Racer and used
their considerable talents to make a
bright colorful adventure that the whole
family could enjoy this is of course an
American adaptation of the beloved manga
turned anime series from the 60s and
while it was a woefully underrated
box-office bomb when it was released to
theaters it's absolutely worth watching
it's got all the gorgeous wachowski
visuals fun and fast-paced action
sequences and world-building through
visual design without all the doom and
gloom of a post-apocalyptic society
constantly on the brink of collapse in
addition to special effects that capture
the feeling of a pop art cartoon brought
to life Speed Racer boasts a
star-studded cast packed with fan
favorites like John Goodman Susan
Sarandon and Christina Ricci despite its
financial shortcomings Speed Racer has
become a cult classic and not just
because of its unique style the
over-the-top artificial look of its
world is paired with the sincerity at
the heart of its story that's rarely
been matched in a movie for kids or for
adults for that matter put it all
together and it's easy to see why it won
over the hearts and minds of millions of
fans since Plus this is a chimpanzee and
ninjas before the matrix explored the
idea of a digital world that existed
alongside reality that was Tron
incredibly stylish wildly fun a product
of pure imagination run wild
the 1982 original is another genre
defining film that paved the way for the
witch s keys to make them magic the big
difference is that rather than
discovering that they're trapped in a
false reality the designers and
programmers who get sucked into the
virtual world of Tron know they're
trapped in a simulation it's getting out
there could be deadly Disney's
cutting-edge cult classic stars Jeff
Bridges is Kevin Flynn a programmer
turned video game arcade owner turned
virtual warrior key Andy's buddies are
up against an artificial intelligence
seeking to increase its own power and
rule the world if that sounds familiar
it's because Tron most likely influenced
at least a few of the ideas behind the
matrix in both visuals and writing it
might be a movie for kids but Tron
explored philosophical ponderings about
the role of technology in our lives and
experimented with what at the time were
brand new advances of computer-generated
images as special effects with two
Academy Award nominations and a great
soundtrack Tron is a fantastic film that
stood the test of time it also got a
similarly underrated sequel in 2010 that
makes for an interesting watch if only
to see how its themes were treated
before and after the matrix redefined
these ideas for pop culture it's worth a
watch and as an added bonus you can brag
to your friends that you watched the
only film entirely inspired by the first
time its creator Steve and Liz Berger
saw the video game pong set in the
dystopian Neo Tokyo in the year 2019
Akira is a piece of art from start to
finish and even the most jaded adults
who think anime is only for kids will be
blown away by the gorgeous art and come
away effective from the masterful
storytelling originally when Akira was
released in 1988 in Japan movie didn't
make much of a splash it was released
the year after in the United States and
it picked up steam with critics and fans
alike today Akira is considered one of
the most important science fiction
movies ever made
not just in anime but in the entirety of
film it's also regarded as a landmark
piece of animation that set the bar for
generations to come
and
influenced thousands of other artists
and filmmakers including the Wachowskis
while it doesn't have the artificial
reality elements of the matrix the
mind-bending story centers around a
young man trying to save his friend from
a nefarious government plot plus there
are some extremely cool motorcycles that
will make you want to take to the
neon-lit open road and amazing character
design that will definitely fool you
into thinking it's a good idea to dress
in head-to-toe red leather if you only
see one movie on this list make it akira
ghost in the shell' the 1995 anime
inspired by a manga of the same name was
initially like many of the movies on our
list of box-office flop as we all
learned from Morpheus though sometimes
things are not as they seem today it's
considered one of the best science
fiction films of all time and it's
absolutely at the top of many best anime
lists as well though released in the
mid-90s ghost in the shell' is set in
the year 2029 in a cyberpunk Japan where
human lives are even more intimately
connected with the machines and
Technology around them than they are
today
following the life of a cyborg agent
specializing in taking down
technological threats this is a non-stop
action thriller where the pacing and
animation will keep you hooked all the
way from start to finish and just like
the matrix it does it all while posing
some serious philosophical questions
about the nature of man and machine it's
no secret that the groundbreaking anime
was a huge influence on the matrix as it
majorly inspired some of the thinking
and visuals of the Wachowskis film
exploring similar themes of identity and
its existence in relation to society
even if you don't want to spend time
pondering all that though you should
still watch it just for the mind-blowing
action sequences that feature animation
that has rarely been equalled check out
one of my new videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss
single one
[Music]